[Music]
good morning Millennials good morning
Millennials I guess it's the extent of
my singing seeing as how all of you guys
hate me
Julian all the time I'm like about to
get my own jewel-like I need to stop no
you just you can drill up into the point
where you get your own jewel totally
just gotta steal other people's jewels
right and I can tell you that your
throne issues are 100% from the jewel
Lenore right yeah that happened to me
like right before
Olivia's wedding because I like hid the
jewel and then all of a sudden I had
shrimp and that's really the only thing
I could get me to stab chillin it's like
it doesn't even matter how cool I don't
put you on brass or anything but are you
an extension yeah okay you're I was
gonna say either your hair grew
overnight but did you wear extensions
this weekend all weekend but they look
like extensions but I'm like I'm like
either I really am so self-centered and
I didn't notice my sister's hair is down
to her breasts or she's but they look so
good I'm wearing extensions they're new
and they're good it's good to call
someone out on their extension I think
for a while I like extensions were
really taboo yeah but I don't feel that
way anymore and like I wore them all
weekend and it looked incredible and I
was in such premium content
why wouldn't I give the toasters my best
as well we're gonna come back with
another like sad weird with one of these
know like I just with my hair sometimes
like it just looks so weird on the show
and I was like no they deserve the
glamour it's a Monday I can serve it up
for you can I tell you something I
started doing that Michelle the woman
who does her hair gave me advice on
because I used to pride myself on like
having the healthiest hair like never
blow-drying my hair and then like I got
like a modicum of Fame and I do my hair
like probably three or four times a week
and I'm afraid that it's taking a toll
on my hair and like I see it breaking
and I feel like hair masks are [__]
but Michelle says they're really not but
she was like just leave your conditioner
in like she's like you can sleep with it
overnight and that's dramatic but when
I'm in the shower I'll do my conditioner
immediately and like put it in a bun and
then I'll like shave my legs and I play
around like singing stuff I'm like ten
minutes later I'll take out the
conditioner my hair is so soft I have a
soft hair issue it's not soft it's just
like moisture you know what I mean
breakage wetness it's the essence of
moisture now I'm you probably are so
confused cuz you're like whoa there's
two Jackie's on the show today because I
really feel like in the past month I've
become heavily influenced by my sister
Jackie like look at my cup whoa like I'm
drinking a beverage a warm beverage with
a ego grip wrap around it like I'm so
Jackie I just place another order from
Rimmel eco whatever Eco grip I placed an
order from Rabab last night
as the revolve yeah no I'm literally
turning into Jackie like I'm doing
spinning today but that really was
unbearable ask not yours because Margot
joined class pass and now she's being
like crazy trying out all these classes
over the city and I had heard about
class pass before and my friends used to
do it and then Margot did it and like
now I'm really so it's what heavily
influenced by my sister's good eye - I'm
not a member I'm soaking up everyone's
like good qualities that's great I don't
I don't take up other people's like
cigarettes you know like I'm not like
that's Julia right no not like a loser
I'm just like I I'm cosmopolitan I like
to grab good qualities wherever I see
them like mr. cosmopolitan right I mean
he was very different in the sense that
he had a beer belly and I'm just trying
to pull a beer belly he would never use
class pass no no which is exactly why we
should be using class pass because I
don't know mr. cosmopolitan was what we
named my previous double chin settler he
like he settled on my face what do you
call him Oh inhabitant he was a similar
oh no no with the bird with the P
parasite he was a [__] parasite on my
Chen but due to the blunder for work of
sharon DZ and me making good choices
like joining class paths is why we no
longer have to say him or talk about him
so class pass if you guys don't know it
is an all-access membership to over
14,000 of the best gyms and fitness
studios all over the world you can go
anywhere you want how you want class
passes everything you need to take
working out fun so basically you paid
them the membership not a gym and then
you get access like a million different
types of classes I'm not need any gyms
it's really cool Mario got me into it so
you can get your first month for free at
class pass calm / toast sorry that was
incorrect get your first month free at
class pass calm / try / toast that's
class pass calm /tr y / toast for your
first month free class pass calm / try /
test and you'll look out later today
we're doing the spinning class and I'm
gonna like I'm gonna blow it up on
Instagram I'm so excited
yeah you know how this thrills me well I
feel like I'm feeling not so great and
maybe I'm thinking
working it like I've tried everything
when it comes to make myself feel better
except working out maybe that's it maybe
because endorphins to make you happy and
happy people just don't shoot their
husbands and you know I don't after
spending the entire weekend with that
I'm ready to shoot him right so you have
to be given great weekends
we had a great weekend it was so intact
um where do we begin
I guess we'll begin on Friday night
speech and I went to Kacey Musgraves so
you went on Saturday overall thought
something concert is that she just is an
incredible talent work of art
masterpiece underappreciated
song with voice sorcery well I have a
bunch of thoughts on it my first was
like and I said this and I didn't mean
it as an insult but I meant like the
concert was almost boring because she
sounds so similar to her iTunes and
Spotify like she doesn't use autotune at
all I just feel like I was at home
listening to Al Bono she changed it up a
little bit along and it's like she just
kept like going oh yeah I felt the same
one it's like she wasn't to like chair
bus up it's like stop singing I'm doing
it different I went to the mean greet
before and I just have to say that [__]
knows how to run meet-and-greet and if
someone who does mean greets I'm taking
her I'm taking some tips from Kacey
Musgraves she is the biggest ring light
that's so flattering and everyone just
comes and takes a selfie oh my god no
dealing with flash no flash I'm doing
that genius
I just gotta like now bring a ring light
with me which is incredibly annoying but
worth it it um anyways the company was
fantastic near town I highly recommend
it was fantastic I chose host day only
thing that I wish is so toasty and like
snitch and I got dressed to the nines me
too and everyone of course looks like a
slob and it's like please try oh you can
see it and the fact you was sitting
behind us like a fellow appreciator okay
it was great it was star-studded your
night was when more stars I think
Phillips was there while we were there
and Maggie Rogers was there yes my night
wasn't that star-studded I guess like I
won't heard I was coming and then they
want to be upstaged
but I did me the toaster who was so like
cute and coy and then her mom told me
that her dad is Darius Rucker
I love and I think me too I love when we
have just like they like also someone
else show me that Robert crafts like
nice is a huge show sir Robert Kraft
nice but that just gets me one step
closer to Giselle 1000 I feel like
Giselle doesn't want to meet me though
cuz like she's like super like you know
insecure around like fellow models ya
know she's not a model who supports I
don't know so like if you're a toaster
and you're related to someone famous or
like you are famous just like let us
know and then we'll talk about like
let's talk about Terry Sarkar this
actual the songstress of our generation
and Ben knows arias record and like
Benji know he's hoody did he no no
people don't miss Darius Rucker he's had
two lives like a huge country star
Hootie of Hootie and the Blowfish
he was in fretful he wasn't but hoody in
the bow fish was with Monica got a
hickey from one of his Ben who's also in
Ted which is probably the biggest
accomplishment in Mayas reference after
that he was just coasted I can't say the
word reference without thinking of that
Lady Gaga video to reference or not
reference gave birth to it put in a
blender vomit and shake it up she's so
crazy she's so great thing she's a busy
we'll get to her she's so busy Phillips
who was at the concert I did not see her
no so in addition to us having just like
a jam-packed week I gave a performance
in Poughkeepsie to a bunch of people who
didn't know who I am it was a corporate
event and I really wished more toasters
had shown up but I didn't promote it cuz
that wasn't my job I mean there were
four toasters there who I just have to
say like toasters are some of the most
supportive people in the world and like
when Ben went outside he and he came
backstage he was like there's like a
couple toasters in the front I was like
thank God because performing for people
who don't know who I am is really hard
they don't get like if you don't get
housewives you don't get mean like you
don't get Instagram you have no idea who
I am
so those four toasters in the front like
I'm forever indebted to them for just
like laughing and screaming while other
people were like hardcore walking out
what did you think of Poughkeepsie did
you take the train like I suggested
shaggy did suggest I take the train oh I
had a wonderful ride up the Hudson Sally
would love it
no I didn't take the train cuz I had a
car and the driver was like so cute he
took us there and back and on the way
back I just played exclusively Taylor
Swift and he knew every single word and
when I got out who's like thank you for
playing Taylor so I had to put her on
now and I Drive back it's like you got a
date that's nice
yeah she's really just
cross-generational I mean which we
already and we had a bunch of birthday
parties I'm gonna be so lost case so
Friday night after we went to case
Musgrave semi mode to Kristin's birthday
and then we went to the lost kings you
know friends of the toast mr. hat and
yeah well they had invited us to the
concert and you had KC tickets and I had
um hiccups hiccups see treachery so we
couldn't go to the concert they did a
show in Brooklyn and they did like their
after-party is set at Markey and then
come on till 1:30 and I got back at like
midnight so it was so perfect and
honestly like they really respected the
hell out of us gave us a great table
right next to the DJ booth so I could
like harass mr. hat mr. hat and try to
like you know make a [__] off button me
mom's like anyway oh my god I got there
like with she had other woman I got
there with the intention of setting my
sister up with mr. hat and then having
seen him cuz I haven't met them because
I wasn't here when they came on the show
I'm having seen him in person
I just realized like I really want to be
mrs. half so sorry my god
was a fight till the death but anyway so
it was so good it was so much fun they
respected the hell out of us and like
honestly I didn't know if I could hack
it at Marquee 1 like beating 26 to being
a grandma and 3 being sober by January I
can't believe you were sober this whole
weekend I know I can't believe it either
I just have to set you guys like I would
not recommend it to anyone like I've
never felt worse
I sent my whole weekend as if I was
hungover like just in bed eating
everything in sight so there was really
no point other than I'll be able to say
I did try driving right and I'm glad
it's like cool to like try something and
stick to it and accomplish it like on
January 31st 7 minute you're gonna have
a drink or just like the next February
first like I'm gonna go to dinner and
drinks that's so annoying cuz I'm not
even gonna be here right now I'm so
annoyed it truly comes out of her hole
like every I just it's not gonna be fun
jacket like I'm just gonna have like a
wine with me get started on Blanc I
stabbing him Blanc
um so what it was just that interesting
people are dying to know where your
sweaters from misguided oki sweaters and
misguided it was no she's so relatable
it was an interesting experiment and
like the loss things were so good and
like the night was so fun that truly I
had the best time regardless of drinking
that's honestly so impressive because
when we got smirky I was like kind of
sober cuz I had worked that night and
like I was like oh this is not gonna be
fun then I took much shots it was a
great time but I'm telling you like it
was objectively fun it was like right
that's where you know the night was fun
not that you were sober and you still
had a good time the music was so good
imagine how China Mieville if we were
like GA and you know they didn't respect
the hell out of the toes like I don't
know how fun that would be
well benzoate was partially ruined did
you hear about this that he got thrown
up on someone threw up like and the
splash hit Ben's shoe and Ben with his
shoes their common projects and like
he's really obsessed with these shoes
and he tells everyone about these shoes
it was like a little splash like get
over it it's a club like what do you
expect this isn't the country club like
relax hey someone throw up on you the
country club like it would warrant the
kind of reaction Ben had his whole night
was earned he had to go home like he was
so annoying he then he just stood there
in silence he's like once we leave oh my
god the funniest isn't Sam came and met
us and she ran up to the table and we
were all standing on one side a table
cuz there was vomit on the other side we
were waiting for it to be cleaned up and
she ran up to the table and literally
standing in the vomit and she has like a
fear of vomit like whatever
claustrophobia is for vomiting like she
has an irrational
oh yeah neither of vomit she runs up
soon people standing around I should say
and it was like no but it sounded like
we were cheering she's a
Oh God did she ever know she said the
mom eventually they were like oh but she
actually was fine and it was crazy
oh and then I realize the only part
about being sober like out out the only
thing that's annoying is like everyone
else being drunken like their motor
skills like they can't get their [__]
together and like everyone's just like
bumping into you and if you're sober you
notice it and like I've my shoes I was
very like the most beautiful shoes my
favorite pair of shoes my Kacey
Musgraves shoes yeah and I was like
worried about people stepping on my foot
and like honestly no one did except for
the [__] snitch kept stepping on my
foot I had to throw my shirt away that I
wear that night it's literally in my
trash and yes it was very cheap from
ASOS but still Margit was wearing this
beaded jacket that every time she was
like moving she catched like a thread
unravel me I was I walked out [__]
naked because my whole shirt came off
you were Thomas unravel now she was
still annoying and I literally had to
throw my jacket away and like yes her
jacket was like nice inexpensive and
mine was a $2.00 shirt it doesn't matter
those things and she was like it's fine
it's for Bezos I'm like [__] you buy it
and I'm like I know you do baby that
jacket [__] then the next night and
literally we were out till 4:00 a.m. and
I just want to say like you've lost
Kings are ever like in your town
performing out your local water William
please go it went to a city and I was
like we should go that would be like the
epic yeah cuz we have a special place in
our hearts for all right and then mr.
and mrs. hat of course they didn't you
know make it official yet but we were
just one step further it's one step
closer to brother hat uncle hat
yeah Theo's really mr. sad he was really
excited to meet him yeah he's um Theo
had a great weekend too he's okay so
when we got home from the what's at the
lost kings or was it whatever one of the
night we went out Ben took out the oh
and Ben came back into the apartment
screaming crying and Ben was wasted so
I'm like what's wrong
he goes he lifted his leg and so yes
Thea was a boy but he surrounds himself
with a lot of female energy innocence he
gender and I know his parents know and
so he squats and all puppies squat to
pee but eventually when you're a boy
like you have your bar mitts on you grow
out of it you start lifting your leg
Theo never started lifting his leg and
he's still squats like a girl and I
don't care I love him just saving that's
like the equivalent of like when dad's
let their sons play with Barbies you
know like it's like oh I'm so amazing
it's like and nobody cares so that then
came running and screaming he lifted his
like and I didn't have the heart to tell
Ben that like a couple other times when
I walked Theo in the middle the night
when he's so tired he doesn't have the
energy to squat he just like lifts a leg
a little bit and they didn't tell him
squatting is really taxing on God he was
so like happy and proud and obviously
the next morning Theo spotted again just
like regular business as usual but then
thinks like Theo had a moment with him
this weekend
I'm happy for them obviously I'm ready
for Theo to lift his leg because then
he'll stop peeing on his paw and then I
don't have to wash his feet every time
he sees it and c2 says I changed my
sheets last night
it was like a big day for me I never
changed my sheets and honestly like I
felt amazing I mean I called them fresh
cakes in my house and let me have fresh
cakes that's exactly what it is he gets
so excited but so maybe me I'm new like
I never lived in an apartment that had
laundry before cuz I wasn't a princess
you know in New York if you have lunch
in your apartment you're royalty yeah
and I never had that but my new
apartment does and I was saying when I
moved to and it was broken and I haven't
been able to use it literally up until a
month ago and I'm having a hard time
like with sense like I want when my [__]
comes out of laundry for it to smell
like [__] roses and I bought
everything I used I use just like
detergent then it also use like um dryer
sheets
no traffic softener fabric softener and
UNSTOPABLES bubbles and it's not enough
I need more what is like the best
I want the number one [__] I think it's
it's fabrics opera downy fabric soft
that's what I use well maybe your [__]
just now I think no I think maybe it's
like my pipes aren't clean maybe do you
know what I mean but that's beyond
anything I can take over and once I
always like address an issue in my
apartment like with the landlord it
doesn't get fixed for six months and so
I'm just gonna shut my mouth
very ser yeah are we done well the rest
of our weekend we went out again we hit
the town so hard both nights Saturday
night then you went to Kesey Oh none of
my life who enter Dana's birthday and it
was just a grand no time objectively
because I was sober and I had a grand
old time did you catch any of the
opening act unfortunately yes
unfortunately I did and I mean I'm
definitely not like the ideal consumer
for this girls music but she's missing
up so much I could no she's like a
former Dixie chick okay I told you that
and I was wrong oh they have a similar
name and I when I but this girl was like
she looked like 25 she was definitely
not the Dixie chick girl there natalie
is their name and I told you that I
started to lie I'm really sorry oh my
god
yeah I remember when I was there I'm
like oh I'm definitely wrong and nobody
told me that I just like made the
discovery I thought it made a lot of
sense cuz it was pretty packed for her
so I was like oh these are all former
Dixie chick fans like no and if it was
she would have had to sing at least one
Dixie Chicks song and chance true that's
true
it wasn't her I apologize to everyone I
told okay well now I feel duped anyways
are you ready to get into the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast yeah I guess I'm feeling
pretty I'm feelin pretty decent yeah and
like honestly the Fast Five stories
aren't fast no there are all things that
require like a deliberation analysis
wait I had a thought right before I had
a thought like a couple days ago that I
think I might have been onto something
cuz you and I were talking about last
week how like it's literally impossible
for us to not be tired right even like
last night I went to bed at 10:30 and I
woke up today like super late at like
9:15 which is why I look like this and
I'm not wearing lipstick so that's like
11 hours of sleep and I still feel like
absolute trash I'm thinking maybe even
overthinking it this whole time maybe we
don't need that much sleep because like
last week a couple nights I got like
hardcore four or five hours and I felt
amazing he felt horrible
no sorry it was a week before that okay
I remember there was a week last week
where I felt like kind of good even
though I literally I was having so much
trouble the whole week falling asleep
like Ben was passed out I didn't go to
bets like 138 which for me is so late
and then the next morning I felt fine so
maybe we don't need that much eight
maybe we're getting too much no but I've
seen that every level Samnites like I
get so much sleep I'm still tired I get
mean iam sleep I'm so tired
I get little sleep I'm still tired so
you may as well have a good time and
like watch all the TV that you want the
night before right I don't [__] and
we had the bachelors on tonight so not
only drive to go to a workout class but
they might also have to watch about
sorry yeah and the rules which like I
enjoy so much and it's so sad cuz Monday
nights have this like [__] stain on them
for me because are the bachelor honestly
and you don't have too much of you don't
have if you don't want to I'll watch it
I'm gonna be like I wanna be included
but so far the matter like has been fine
like I really like Colton he has some
cool girls it's really the time thing I
enjoy it when I'm watching it but I'm
like I have to like get my [__] together
because if I'm like in bed watching
something I have to have done everything
else I've just showered clean my
apartment do the laundry like and then
if I'm in bed for TV like I'm in bed for
the night but so why don't you just like
watch it in your living room
with half and I play with the tags I get
some work done
in between bachelor-man from Burrell
shower and then enjoy that in from
Rossum vet I love animals so much like
it's so good lalla went to hang with
Emma Roberts yes so now that I've been
like included in some celebrity type
events I really see the behind the
scenes of it all
so one thinks Oh Emma Roberts and lady
not lady well I can are best friends no
not all famous people have planes and
Randall I mean has one and that's why
people like befriend him it's because
the one they Sundance like every bucket
every plane is booked every plane is
charter like you can't get out of there
it's like the biggest weekend in this
small town of Utah
so Randall having a plane like of course
any celebrity is gonna want to get on it
and so they just have to be friends with
Rondo and wala totally and Emma's a big
fan of the in front world she loves
Stassi Oh does oh right your podcast
yeah that's a good episode if you guys
are ever like looking for a podcast
that's cuz you've consumed all the
morning toast hear your heart but maybe
you did my interview should head over to
our patreon patreon comm slash the
morning toast we have three more
episodes to do this month and we're
doing one today and I'm so excited I
really am ready to do my house tour
except I need a new coffee table the one
that I have now like make someone throw
up do you think maybe you could do it
just like no because also this huge
piece of art that I got above my thing
was delayed it's coming hopefully like
in a week so once that comes I will
start hmm okay okay first story the only
way to have one more thing I want to say
I'm just like so channel of me so I've
been looking for this coffee table that
doesn't exist and a bunch of I whenever
you want something on the internet that
you can't find like ask the toasters and
the find it for you and a bunch of
people were like I couldn't find the
table but there's this influencer and
she has a really similar table and she
spoke about her she couldn't find him so
she had one made like basically the same
story is made and they told me about her
and I [__] forgot and I couldn't
remember her name and it was like
annoying me so much and then when we
were drunk on some well I was drunk on
Saturday night we were all sitting
around and I was showing everyone
something on Instagram and I like touch
my phone in a weird way and all of a
sudden I popped up on this girl's
Instagram it was like magic I said yeah
and I took a screenshot cuz I was like
I've been looking for this girl's
Instagram and I said to her damn and she
danced me out so like I feel really
weird about it
that's pretty like a complete stranger
it's pretty weird but a fellow
influencer is that weird no I'd be
father's a co-worker a colleague yeah I
just want to know who made it okay
speaking of co-workers and colleagues
Andy Cohen and the Real Housewives get
festive at baby shower the stars were
aligned on Saturday for Andy Cohen the
watch what happens live posts in many
Real Housewives stars gathered in their
life for his baby shower which was
hosted by Kyle Richards Ramona Singer
nene leakes Teresa Giudice and Mickey
gum Wilson aka me oh geez but I read
somewhere I was just hosted by Kyle no
it wasn't okay it was hosted by all of
them but it was in LA and I was from Ali
so I'm sure she did the heavy lifting
but it was hosted hosted by all the oh
geez right even though like Bravo paid
for it 100% and there were cameras so
I'm sure like Bravo people actually like
hey I'm sorry yes but planted I mean I
think for sure because if Kyle Richards
had planted she would have had her go-to
event planner and someone tagged the
event planner and it was a woman and it
wasn't that guy who is just Kyle's
parties yes but like I do think they
paid for some things and all of the
house eyes flew themselves out oh really
yeah and he said that in history she's
like he was like I appreciate you guys
all coming you know buying plane tickets
leaving your families and you know
non-rival Bravo's dime oh my god yeah I
didn't see that she was at the palm
restaurant in Beverly Hills the theme
was appropriately and adorably a star is
born which was a great theme but then
they like didn't do anything with the
theme past that right because the theme
is all about addiction and there's a
child coming into the world and it
doesn't relate except for the fact that
it's a star being born right but they
like didn't even play shallow you know I
mean they might have but we just don't
know no but we mean it was filmed there
were so many people that like I was
following before that I was really
grateful for like Darren obviously but
also Anthony Mazal Ella I don't
pronounce his last name right he's the
bartender Booker on March Evans I he was
just like fun and cool and I met him a
couple times so I follow him on
Instagram and he had literally the most
premium Instagram stories I wonder if he
edited to his highlights I tell you I
watch obviously Darren's
up like 70 holman Dorinda
Kyle Lisa racer ever but like it was
everyone filming Lisa Rinna so her story
you didn't even like really need to
watch no no I was really filming
everything and I feel like I got a 360
experience of what happened there was an
entire wall covered in a floral
arrangement with a giant star decoration
on it similarly the golden white cake
had a star is born' written on it um
from Orange County New Jersey in Beverly
Hills to Atlanta Cohen spent the day
standby housewives from all over the
country other women in attendance
included in these fourth okay included
every single housewife except and now I
have a list of who was not countess but
she addressed it she's on tour
I have a list or maybe I do but so I
wanted to know what the rules were like
Phaedra's not a housewife and she hasn't
been for a decent amount so I don't
think that there were really worlds like
they invited all of the housewives are
like people who are important to Annie
and I don't think they expected that
many people to okay but like well
actually if Nene was a host I think Nene
and Phaedra are cool maybe that's why
she was invited but like where's Carlton
Gebbia you know nobody what are the
rules the rules were just like invite
the housewives and I think teaser is
like still she's still relevant she's
yeah okay so this is who was not there
okay LuAnn well she is Diane she was on
tour Bethenny speaking gig but in LA ooh
Tinsley ooh melissa gorga
she had her daughter's gymnastics thing
I saw on her Instagram oh my god that's
so sad I feel like most of order we've
had the best time I know who's sad for
Margaret cause like think it's like
hanging out with other people
Kelly dad she just lived a few miles
north oh but she's like you're not oh
she said oh I saw actually an Instagram
comment she said she was on vacation and
she had this trip planned months ago
even though I would cancel my whole
[__] trip for that right but I don't
think they real I'm telling you like
they didn't realize it was gonna be such
a big event Lisa Vanderpump this is the
biggest question mark and we'll get all
into it yeah Monique Deandra
she had a work thing and she's been
working on with her husband for months
in advance okay Kerry that's weird cause
she wouldn't research opportunity kandi
oberus mm-hmm Porsha and Shamari Wow
that's weird the Elisaveta from one is
obviously like the butcher nari because
she lives there her and like and and
given what we think happens this season
on Vanderpump I mean on Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills it ain't good you know
yeah she's just like she has a weird
relationship because like the way that
it seems like the season is gonna be
going it's like she's done with the
network she's done with everyone but she
still is tied from Vanderpump rules
right also if she were to have been
there she would have been a host because
she is an OG like she's just like hi all
right and they might have had it at like
pump right well that's a really good
call it's weird that they it's not weird
that they had at the Palm because of
Bruce Bozzi and now like Annie said in
his speech and like he's such a good
friend like almost to a fault he was
like now this will be like the palm is
gonna be staple on every house I store
though totally and the palm in and of
itself is like a reputable institution
but now it's like irrelevant
they have one at the airport so like how
reputable could it be and they don't
really have a menu horrible
yeah hf k now i think the pom is
chillies because it's at the airport
right and when you think of the palm
like in new york there was one and then
there was two and there was one in
Beverly Hills and others one in East
Hampton like it's very Ralph Lauren like
you have to wear a collared shirt and
you have to order the New York Strip but
then it's like you can't even get in New
York Strip in your sewing I want your
collared shirt at the airport no and
it's like it's at the airport by the way
it's a government shutdown over I think
it's almost over if someone told me like
Ben told me that they'd reach something
so that it would restart like the the
issue isn't solved but the government
will be back up and running
look I just wanna make sure everyone's
getting paid yeah i'm i think it's it's
gonna be back up and running soon
because like everyone's talking about
the shutdown i figure if they fixed it
like everyone will be talking about it
they do get back pay oh they do okay
we mean check I don't know if you're
talking about online or offline we were
talking about it online and I looked
into Italy because like TSA workers not
showing up obviously not if you're not
gonna get paid but if there's back pay
right so it's like the government's good
for it
or they'll just borrow it from China Kim
Zolciak also wasn't there but she's not
really a housewife she's more like a
Bravo Liberty she's like a Stasi until
Phaedra was a surprise for Andy from
Nene I think that Andy likes Phaedra and
fired her just because like the audience
like they demanded it of him okay so
let's get into the details because it
looked lit well first it looked just
like you know co-workers mingling but
then took a fancy brunch angle holiday
party they were making contact recording
for radio Andy right and then someone
gave Lee Simran and the microphone and a
few drinks and she it boozled everyone
into turning it into a party at
Bagatelle a date suite literally was
like get off your [__] asses for Andy
Cohen I'm talking to you nene leakes
like i am so afraid of me like if
there's any house i might want to run
across it's her she's too powerful and
lisa arena couldn't care less
no Lisa Rinna was the clear MVP of the
day her body is so insane like her that
bio her butt yeah her butt is so perfect
she really has the perfect body and that
thing she was wearing like I would
actually look like a moose in because it
picks up that material it picks up every
little crevice and crustacean and
homegirl looked so good it's really
crazy how like Andy has created a
generation of women who are like so
fabulous and like
a lot of people like to say like the
housewives setbacks like a study back
feminism decade it's like no it's not
actually no he's given all these women
like who lives like wherever they were
before if they had success earlier their
lives like a renewal you know yeah and
like an empowered at renewal did you see
your mother falling off the table like
she caught herself on my bed again
disastrous yes I did okay so who do you
think was best dress and who do you
think was worth stress oh you know I've
even look at the people's outfits that's
such a good call I was someone there was
a thread about it and the toasters and
so then I really started to think and
then I realized like honestly a lot of
them like really which was not into the
like average yeah Kyle's du/dt Kyle's
story I mean Instagram post of her white
suit yeah it was like literally black
they turned like at the bottom was
covered if I didn't see mine dirt she
was like that everything so funny so
relatable she looks good she looked good
but like I don't know the suit was
wearing her everyone looks the same I
don't even remember anyone's out like
Jane
always but leopard boot it wasn't like
my favorite look of hers and then there
was someone I think it's a Potomac wife
wearing that Fendi jumpsuit like like
NASCAR style and while it didn't like I
didn't love it on her but I also don't
know her like I wish Erica Jane wanted
born that right I don't um I really
don't remember what anyone wore that's
so great it wasn't even like I was just
thinking like what does everyone who's
hanging out with you right but I was
everyone was hanging out with everyone
yeah it seems very inclusive and it
seems like the housewives like from
their respective cities like they all
put their differences aside like Leeanne
and Brandi took a selfie right and if
you think about it like there are a lot
of housewives who I think think that
they're better than everyone else like
Bethenny definitely think she's better
and I think that's maybe why she didn't
come like she's on Shark Tank she does
want to be looped in with like this
group of housewives but like if she had
gone she couldn't she would have been
like the Lisa Rinna of it right like oh
total going into it like who would you
have thought us I mean he honestly
probably Lisa Rinna and it's in her
hometown she's comfortable right things
expected Kyle by the way like has a
pretty good voice oh yeah like Erika
Jayne didn't perform right so I think
that like a lot of the girls it's like
awkward because they really think that
they're I think some of the franchise's
think that they're better than others
you know I think some of them are I
think Beverly Hills think that thinks
that they're better than everyone and
also is in their hometown so it's there
definitely was like a dynamic that once
ever it started drinking it shifted but
like I think like to Lisa things such
and the some of the oh geez like they
are like Nene
she's better than everyone Bethany
Teresa and they are but like when you
all get together and you're all equals
now like you're just there for Andi
it definitely makes like a weird dynamic
maybe I think that's why the beginning
you would see like it wasn't turned up
it was like a little weird yeah these
people who have never met each other but
they definitely don't shade at each
other yeah for me um Cynthia Bailey was
best dressed Oh yellow yellow suit also
Marlo oh my god I'm so glad that they
included mark Justin Marlo's outfit for
me yeah but she is she's so tall miss
Jackie she's too tall and she's like
she's a grown woman
yeah I gotta say I'm almost too old for
now good I'm really glad they included
her like she gets shafted all the time
like she is the storyline of many a
season and regardless if you like her or
not like she never gets opportunity to
be a housewife and like explain herself
or just like get her own air time but
she's always contributing to the
juiciness and she always gets on the
reunion so I'm really glad they included
her because she deserves it she's like a
Judith Leiber bagand and na Rihanna
Grande dress and so for that reason I'm
in yeah Eva was wearing jeans and
everyone is the kido-san is or what she
wears to work there's a thread in the
toasters of what would you do to have
dinner I read a wall okay hold on I'm
gonna pull of the highlights nothing I'm
just like an attendee yeah because there
were a lot of attendees like that woman
who impersonates all the housewives amy
was she there
yes John Mayer John Mayer so we did you
watch the current mood with John Mayer
last night I never watch it it's at
Instagram show he does it's like it's
kind of cute and stupid but last night
he had Andy on to do like a whole
debrief and Maggie Rogers performed like
literally in a tiny room in his basement
with an iPhone but he said the funniest
thing you know the picture like a that
went viral of all the housewives and
Andy and John and John was like
afterwards I realize I'm like why didn't
I say all right after the picture was
taken
all right now one with just Andy like
it's an iconic photo that's like never
been taken for them like John Mayer is
randomly in it and he was like I can't
believe I didn't have the self-awareness
just to be like all right let me hop out
for one no but it's like who's gonna
tell John my hair to get out of the
picture right certainly one for me my
worst dressed was Giselle from Potomac
cuz she was wearing just like a pool
cover up with my mom's
it was this one Oh terrible terrible
like she looks like she was at the pool
not like the performance of a lifetime
oh she was on the table the whole time
like from the beginning yes arena and
she almost fell did you see her um
oh no I didn't see that and so
for that reason like and it's weird you
would think the housewives would be like
up on the table in one second like just
being like so like some of them are
being shy they were being really shy
even to eat like she stayed on the chair
she didn't get on yeah so um John Mayer
said something else really funny he's
like I was sitting next to this woman
and he's like I didn't know who she was
and John was I mean and II was thinking
like I think it was Teddy Mellencamp
John Malcolm Sutter and he's like oh
yeah she didn't he told me she was John
Mellencamp's daughter and he was like so
are you single and she was like well I'm
currently married I think was like I
just thought the use of the word
currently was really weird
definitely he blew her but honestly if
you were talking to John Mayer that's
what Andy said that's what you would say
I'm currently married and if John Mayer
ask you if you're single like you think
like oh he's interested right and it's
like I'm currently married currently but
that could change like depending on what
you say next I can't find the thread
wait was it fly on the wall is that
really I think so keep talking I'm gonna
look for it okay I'll just read you know
enews account okay that's according to
you'll you'll read someone who couldn't
some boring [__] according to an insider
the room was quote filled with love the
source added it's so much fun for the
different cast members to hang out no
drama
just lots of love for Andy the inside of
the party looks like it was fit for
royalty and then okay thank you okay so
someone was a very interesting question
in the toasters I want to hear the
lengths everyone would have gone to to
have been a fly on the wall at Andy's
baby shower I'll go first
I wouldn't give him peak a blow job well
Simon then can been creepily watching as
to join and that's not really saying
much and then they also edit the picture
of the guy from fire festival who was
supposed to seconds dick right okay hold
on I'm just like pick it up slow there's
thousands of comments oh my god some of
them I mean I'm not gonna read all them
oh god okay hit us and I won't say names
you guys were also it's a safe space um
I would let Gina talk to me about how
fast Robin can hang a TV and Madison
Marie Parks Valletta as much as she
wanted for the next five years
Wow I would have a conjugal visit with
juicy Joe these are things people would
have done to have been invited or just
been a fly on the wall I would have
gotten engaged 19 times I'm in a
prostitution [__] I'd wear a short
dress panelist and sit with legs wide
open in front of PK and Ken oh man
that's so fun one road I don't know feel
that to it they were like I would take a
family man to the airport I would have
had a three-way with Tom Shannon
Valentimes shorts when they were dressed
as women
honestly that's not like that crazy oh
this one's good this is what someone
would do
just to me but you should be so lucky I
would watch busy tonight for 48 hours
straight
I would like Kim Zolciak kiss me I would
marry Tom D'Agostino and give up my
countess title I would have sat down for
lunch with Frankie Grande I would have
stopped being friends with Taytay and
Stephanie I didn't know oh my god
Melania judases song in the beginning
when she's rapping she's like grab my
girls Tate and Stephanie oh my god
that's so funny I defended weak on scary
Island with Kelly Bensimon taking
pictures of me I would be the surrogate
for the baby
oh that's surrogate - so said she wasn't
am i dead
maybe she was so the baby's being born
in LA and they're just doing watch
happens live LA until then
hey sup what's happening I think and he
said that either like he wants to be in
LA until the baby's born for some reason
and I have to assume it's because that's
where the homegirls out interesante
that's an interesting factoid that's
well interesting also uh Jerry O'Connell
and Rebecca our main were there yes it's
obviously like the party opened up after
a while and a bunch of other people came
right it was like they were almost
sudden like Bravo Jason people into the
room and it makes you think like if it
were in New York like no I didn't see
many ther sponsors there I don't know
any Phillips yeah but it's anyone who
just like an actual friend of Andy and
we're not there around ago is she yeah
okay okay oh no we're not there Jerry
O'Connell's they're obviously yeah okay
not yet sister we're a lot of people
that were just like bystanders yes well
I think they were filming broad there
were cameras there I didn't see a camera
someone said that they saw cameras I did
not do you think it and I'll be I don't
think I don't see but I just trust what
people on the internet say because I
really like I think that they send in
the M by to all the Housewives like they
did have to pay for their own fights and
I don't think that they expected that
like pretty much every housewife would
calm and it was gonna be what it was
like and that it would then turn into
maggot oh I feel like Bravo I was like
so good I mean Andy has done everything
for Robert like Bravo is what it is
because of Andy but they're also so good
to him like they moved the show to LA so
he could like be with this kid you know
yeah yeah that is like like he is brob
like he's the head of the network it's
no he's not pretty like he's almost no
he's not he doesn't even work for Bravo
anymore technically he works for most
talkative productions it's in his book
he scored a huge deal where he most
talkative is now his like production
company and Bravo like own
or something like he started it it's
like he works for himself now
interesting yeah okay someone says a
bunch of the toasters are saying in the
comments that they did see cameras okay
that makes me happy I mean they'll be
epic
but what moment it's just like a vlog
yeah I'm sure that's something yeah like
7 March Robbo to be calm for sure or the
after show yeah ok are any more thoughts
about that before we move on no I just
loved it like I was so happy and I was
really following along like the whole
day yeah I wish like the music was a
little better but that's it yeah but if
you think about it like really it was
their generation it was Donna Summer
but like stone totally could do better
totally and the fact that there was no
performances when like Erika Jayne was
there John Mayer was there LuAnn de
Lesseps could have been there yeah have
you seen her video to James Kennedy
happy no when people do that Marilyn
Monroe rendition a mr. president like
they did it and I'm Breaking Bad any
much I want to die like I think that is
something that the world needs to stop
doing because first of all nobody can do
it and second of all like you're not
Marilyn Monroe and even it was a little
cringy when she did it and she was like
a sex symbol random women doing it is
[__] terrible and I hate it so much
and I never don't feel uncomfortable
watching someone be like happy then say
I want to die let's stop stop Marilyn
been roaming in 2019 starting now okay
but speaking of performances of a
lifetime Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
surprise Las Vegas audience with shallow
duet and sex on stage right essentially
falling in love and community adultery
so she sings cello at her residency
which is just amazing and I guess he had
come cuz he hasn't seen one yet and he
also surprised her on stage and no she
surprised him by inviting him on stage
yeah he was still wearing his lanyard
like he really didn't know he was coming
yeah and his hat which he then took off
and there was just so many ways about it
totally there were so many weird moments
about it the first is that when she's
singing he's sitting on the piano just
like staring at her like like like she
was his newborn baby like like when you
have that look I'm just like oh and
inspiring like and then when she when he
started singing she's down on her knees
mm-hmm just staring at him the same way
like
no but she was like yeah like and she
was crying and he was crying too it's
just all very weird like I just want to
say there's one thing to like really
love your coworker and have great
chemistry and just like be good friends
it's another to literally cry when they
say look it's weird it's weird it's
weird because like he is a married man
and so is she
she's a gay I was right but whatever and
it's just weird like this expression of
love and like I'm the one hand you could
chalk it up to like yes they have a deep
connection and to like maybe they were
really getting into the role because
this was literally the movie come to
life yeah a live version available
except without the addiction they never
cried in the movie went each other
saying no it's so weird I think was
definitely a surreal moment and like for
her this is like a major opportunity
they're in the midst of awards season
they've both been nominated for this you
know this movie this song and it's an
overwhelming feeling and now here they
are like doing a live rendition and I'm
sure it's overwhelming but it's like the
way that they love each other and like
the way he's like holding her arms yeah
this is like and the way he put his arm
around her we haven't sitting at the
piano and then she took his arm and is
like I'm sorry
you know it's because intimate as hell
and then the next night at the SAG
Awards last night Bradley Cooper was
alone she was there with her agent slash
fiancee Christian Kirino but it's all
too weird I feel like there's stuff I
mean he brought his mom and his mom is
so funny like she was sitting there with
her sunglasses on inside like Anna fur
coat like she's an epic like
Philadelphia mom but I feel like there's
definitely something with him and Irina
Shayk because and they're not married
no they're just together and they have a
child together so you think of them as
like a family and Bradley Cooper is a
good guy and he was like a model lot
like a womanizer just like loved models
like Leonardo DiCaprio vibes and amongst
one of the many models he was like hang
outwith he got Irina print pregnant I
don't think this is just my like
speculation he got her pregnant
obviously not on purpose and she decided
to keep it and he's a good guy like he's
not like he was raised right his mom
like he's a good mom
he loves his mom like you could tell
guys guys who love their moms love their
wives so like she guys decided to get
pregnant and he's doing the right thing
like he's sticking around he's not gonna
be like a deadbeat dad he's being right
out he's being a good guy sticking
around not leaving
helping take care of the baby but I
don't think he's in it he's I'm in love
and that picture of them at will did
Wimbledon is all you need to know and
like how many reports of them fighting
at a restaurant we need to see right so
they're obviously just like he's in it
for the for the right reasons and she's
also in it for the wrong reasons like
she just wants me mrs. Bradley Cooper
you know cuz I didn't even think she
wants me anymore because I I think she
got the life she wanted and she's very
unhappy because her husband is on stage
making out Lady gaga
right essentially with his eyes right so
I just look there's something weird
there and then Lady gaga I don't think
Christian Kareena was a great lover for
a lifetime I do think that Taylor Kinney
was but that's just me Green and so it's
like anything after Taylor Kinney like
doesn't even matter if you're with
Christian Kirino and in love with
Bradley Cooper when you really just let
me Taylor Kinney and I think Christian
Kareena was just definitely like happy
to be invited to these things and he's
like the irina shayk around also he
would be going cuz like he's her agent /
manager so it would not be going now he
doesn't have to use up like they can get
another plus-one you know for the team
ya know cuz he gets a plus-one now right
so it's it's good but I don't think I
don't think he gets invited like unless
like if yours is an agent know what you
need like a handler
yeah publicist and like an assistant yes
so it could've been him I mean that's
just like such a step down yeah but no
it's like two birds one stone
yes it's a handler and he by the way had
the greatest seat ever last night he was
in on the entire show uhm well speaking
of the SAG Awards let's recap them the
highlight of the night at least for me
who watched only the first five minutes
so this was the highlight of the first
five minutes actually watch some it
Jeffery Owens one shame for Trader Joe's
job featured in sags opener Jackie same
I forgot all about that when they put
him on I'm like that guy looks familiar
who is that and then he talked about
Trader Joe's and I'm like I went in on a
rant
I'm with then because he didn't know who
he was when they put him on I didn't
think he looked familiar but everyone
was cheering and then I was like I had
this inkling when he said he was just
struggling actor and then when he said
Trader Joe's I was like yes more so than
ever Jeffery Owens is an actor they
opened the show with people like telling
their stories of actor dumb also Mike
Meyers was in a movie Bohemian Rhapsody
but would anybody I don't know but I'm
gonna watch it because apparently it's
so good like snitch loved it yeah but
there's a lot of drama she said it was
better than greatest showmen
she do you know he said it was good no I
want to see it too but like there's so
much drama surrounding it and I was
actually watching daily pop to meet you
me let's get into this okay so the drama
around Bohemian Rhapsody is that the
producer on the show
direct-drive singer his Brian singer who
is like a very well-known pedophile
predators he there's tons of allegations
against him nothing has ever been proven
obviously but it's like known in the
he's like a Kevin Spacey open sea
everyone knows and now things are not
coming out about him but like very
slowly and so the movie like glad with
the double a the organization they do
awards to they pulled their nomination
for Bohemian Rhapsody they're not going
to include them anymore because he preys
on LGBT youth LGBTQ youths excuse me so
I want a lollipop they were like is it
fair to punish an entire cast and crew
of people who aren't predators just for
the mistakes of one person and no it's
not but at the same time we're never
gonna get anywhere if we keep like
rewarding predators right and keep using
this like oh the you know the lighting
guy right family right keep Bryan Singer
in the award shows however he was [__] I
read the people like the cast the crew
they make their money regardless if they
win a GLAAD award or a SAG Award agreed
it doesn't affect that it's just like
should rami malek not get the award
because he was in a movie directed by
predator and honestly yeah he shouldn't
Bryan Singer was fired from the movie
before completion so like the studio Oh
sort of like so bits and addendum that
is an important and interesting factoid
that is interesting and important
because mate he's no longer like
profiting off of this but he did get
paid like ten million dollars sure but
you know what that's chump change in
Hollywood that's true and I haven't seen
the movie but I feel like when I see it
I'll feel even stronger that like that
the movie the whole movie shouldn't go
down because of one person's like
terribleness except for the fact that
everyone didn't know and everyone who
was in the movie like what semi
supporting it but that's also just
Hollywood like right so they know it
like he's not this isn't just like the
ones brew and the one thing and it's
like how can you support like literally
people in the room last night at sag
Wars I'm sure our predator is like right
you know no but Hollywood has to decide
like is time up or not you can't be
selected for title for who time's up and
it's like times only up for the people
who are getting caught right no no times
up if there's an allegation and it's
substantial and there have been for
years like sorry times up and sorry if
that makes rami malek not get an award
it's not like he's starving on the
streets and this is gonna affect
there'll be another movie sorry it's
like
to feel bad they're not being the
casting crews not being punished these
are the elitists who are just gonna get
to go to award show and not win like
it's fine it's fine and also but then I
feel that type of way with the movie the
upside Kevin Hart Bryan Cranston the
best movie I've seen in a long time and
for a lot of reasons like it's not
getting the play that it deserves one
because of Kevin Hart and people are
punishing the movie because of that and
two I guess it was originally produced
by Harvey Weinstein and Miramax had to
sell it and now it's someone else but I
guess Harvey Weinstein was involved in
the making of the movie and you know why
right they're being selective after
having seen the movie no the whole movie
shouldn't suffer and we shouldn't suffer
because of those fuck-ups in Hollywood
like we deserve to see that movie Bryan
Cranston deserves for us to see that
movie it's the performance of a lifetime
but so if the movie what my heart really
wants his name was on it had it been
made yet I'm not sure that's important
I'm just saying so now we're being
selective about what gets cancelled and
what doesn't right and Hollywood is all
about now it's like we're done we're out
of the closet we're not hypocrites
anymore like we're fine we're we're
catching up but you can't just pick
things to capture to to be upset with
and then not pick other things right and
it says Justin from Taylor pop always
points out it's like billionaire boys
club that movie that was made with Kevin
Spacey and it literally went direct to
DVD because of all the allegations not
coming Spacey but it was like that was a
legit movie that people spent like years
working on it just like fell into the
dumpster yeah maybe now people will like
when they go to take any job they're
like you know in this movie I might not
get my Oscar because we know this guy's
a freak or maybe the studio's when
they're hiring people will be like oh
maybe we shouldn't like just reward
let's cut back on predators there's
terrible rumors about totally because
you know there are also people out there
who don't have terrible rumors and who
are hardworking directors actors and
producers this is true
like Jeffery Owens oh my god yeah I love
him sorry quote so somewhere in the
middle of the road in my life I found
myself in the dark wood of unemployment
and dead but instead of switching
careers like a sane person I took a job
at the local Trader Joe's to see if I
can hang in there with my career he said
during the SAG Awards opening montage
which features Hollywood's heavy hitters
reminiscing and reminding the camera
that quote I am an actor it's actually
worked out pretty well he added The
Cosby Show star fame took on new life on
a photo of him working in the New Jersey
location of Trader Joe's went viral in
September
he got a resounding applause and I just
[__] love him and someone give him a
goddamn job they did right Tyler Perry
ya know and he'll be fine now
I loved that did you watch the hosts
what did you think of her
I watched bits and pieces so I didn't
get enough of the host E vibes which I
enjoyed because she wasn't bothering me
yeah I watched her like drink bit with
Smithers yeah whatever yeah at the
beginning like there was a couple like
really awkward moments where like it was
quiet and I wanted to die but for the
most part I think she did a good job and
the bar really for the SAG Awards like
is so low it's basically said it's
basically sagging this is the most
important award show this weekend and
actually I had been watching I'm Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 1 and 2 on what I
guess was TNT so when it finished
I was happened to be watching yes TBS
and when it finished I happened to be
watching the SAG Awards so I was like ok
and then I was like maybe I'll dabble in
rent live oh I'm sorry
rent semi live rent not live anymore not
quite live rent forced to use
pre-recorded footage after star Brendan
hunt breaks his foot Fox had to make a
last-minute switch to it's live
television production of Jonathan
Larson's Tony and Pulitzer Prize when he
needs to go on Sunday after star Brandon
Hunt broke his foot during a Saturday
night dress rehearsal producers decided
to air portions of the program
pre-recorded ok they added the whole
program they aired the whole program
pre-recorded except for last 3 minutes
where the original cast and the new sad
cast reunited the United and Tang us on
the announce and when me me like is
overdosing they were live for that
Tonight Show you hit it out of the park
she was literally crying real tears but
the camera wouldn't focus on her face
like [__] get it together it was such
a [__] show you cannot even watch it I
was just keeping up a Twitter I just
[__] no it was such a [__] show I was
watching it and at first I was like oh
my god like what am i watching this is
community theater and then I was like no
that's an insult to people who do
community challenges this was an 8th
grade musical by a rich middle school
that has too much money for set to the
theater department and not enough talent
totally quote last night during our
performance in front of a live audience
one of our cast members sistene and in
sustained an injury Vanessa Hudgens who
plays Maureen explained
a visit to the hospital confirm that
Brennan hunt our Roger broke his foot
and will be unable to perform tonight
but rent has always been about community
resiliency and bouncing backs so the
show much go on okay I don't know whose
error that was added RuPaul's Drag waste
Queen Valentina who plays angel okay I
just want to say I know very little
about theater and music house but I do
know that there's this thing called the
understudy and I want to know where that
person was there was no understudy for
the star um all eight of these people
were pretty much equally stars but and I
guess none of them had understand this
guy was a big enough star that him
breaking his foot required that they use
pre-recorded footage yes but I think
it's not like he was someone like I
think if any one of these eight people
have broken their foot the show I know
Roger really is like the start of the
movie know but also like Jordan Fischer
was okay let me just get it I watched it
I watched the beginning and by the way
it's add to the [__] show for like the
first ten minutes of the show a bunch of
people with a certain cable provider it
wasn't working I just I don't understand
how that can happen like when you were
[__] boss I'm [__] bucks you don't
have an understudy I watched the
beginning I fast forwarded through the
middle and then I watched the end and
the beginning was truly an atrocity and
what what happened it was there was
never any dialogue if I hadn't seen the
movie in my place not like 10 years ago
so Isis was I was ready for a refresher
you know I still could have been
surprised and shocked and awed I had no
[__] clue what was going on in the
plot and they just sang a song sang
another song there was no like dialogue
literally any time someone had to say
something they were singing it like they
was never there was no acting it was so
[__] confusing and then it's like
there's so much subject matter here and
it's and it's like deep subject matter
you know with drugs and disease yeah and
love and it was just completely lost I
had no clue what was going on if I
hadn't ever seen Brent before like I
would have had a note like why is Nene
shaking I didn't know she was a drug
addicts like right it was just so so
weird and like no one ever it's like
they it's like they rehearsed every
scene and no one ever like put it
together and watched it and be like what
are we singing it was almost like they
just took clips from rehearsal and
stitch them together right so then of
course not everyone was getting there
all because it
so rehearsal but still I thought that
the performance is like we're fine I
didn't feel like it was lacking in terms
of you know heart
it was just lacking in terms of talent
brand I mean Vanessa Hudgens really did
everything that she could to lifted the
show up I'm so glad she keeps getting
these roles like she got grease Rizzo
and she always gives it everything
rehearsals yeah yeah she and it's like
four so for her
whew Stoller solo performances and when
she sings um take me or leave me with
Joanne like Roger wasn't involved in
those so why couldn't those have been
there I've I don't know and also um
Maureen when she sings out tonight
Tinashe and she did a really good job
but I just felt like I was at a Tinashe
concert and she was doing a cover of
rent right like it was for in rehearsal
was a dress rehearsal were they wearing
their costumes yeah everything was
exactly how it would have been they were
obvious you know like doing staging and
lighting and cameras and everything was
strong and then Kayla said it wasn't it
yes who did she play she played the
counselor of countless notes she played
counselors nails and then they also just
like used her voice wherever they write
it yeah it's like everyone loves Kayla
said I'll put her on camera right and
but like they didn't even use her well
enough um in the end like they you sort
of hit some high notes that idina menzel
used to be able to hit right and her
microphone wasn't working like it was
just and it was like the woman standing
after like I believe had a microphone he
just could have like put it yeah it was
just a train wreck so I didn't wait and
it was a such a trainer and I'm just in
my room like being like wow being a
theater critic someone who loves this
sort of thing like I you know I had a
countdown going on my phone for a hair
spray right like you can put up with a
lot of like dumb [__] because I
understand like it's live or semi live
and you know these people are getting
out of breath whatever hairspray live
like a [__] dumpster fire like
horrific this I was like oh my god how
are they [__] this up so badly so I
go to Twitter just you know read some
funny tweets and yeah everyone is like
crying on the floor beautiful emotional
unmoved
I can't stop crying ja floor I was like
wait what and that's why Twitter is
literally the worst place in the world
because it's just the opposite of truth
yeah and like I don't want to say it
because I love that they do these like
live musical renditions but like they're
always bad they're always bad
for Greece yeah Greece was an put
pan-pan Peter no I know hem come Peter
was terrible also sound of music Carrie
Underwood what I was gonna say hairspray
terrible and it's like I don't want them
to stop because I think it's like a
great day and I love theater and I love
it and they always choose good musicals
but like at some point it's like when do
we stop know when it's like why why are
they so bad like what's the issue I
can't I can't even articulate it and
then at first I was like this set makes
no sense there's just like running
around and then when they zoom down a
few times there's like no this set is
actually kind of brilliant like they
really tried to recreate New York City
they had audience members everywhere
people were complaining that there was
too much like focus on the audience I
mean I must have fast forwarded and
missed that because I didn't feel about
it all I guess at one point they had a
microphone like over the audience and
they were cheering too loud and you
couldn't hear the song whatever that was
the least they're probably fine and then
apparently what they did last night for
the live audiences they just all sat
around and sang the songs right so they
still put on a show just for like the 30
people I really like that was so amazing
but that's probably by the people the
same people who are on Twitter said that
this show is yeah and I didn't see that
they recorded what they were doing on
stage last night like for the audience
and they're gonna release it like as a
DVD I'm all set yeah - full Roger yes he
moves around he's important but he could
have done in a wheelchair totally and
like people wheeled him around or just
like me or a boot he wound up doing the
last scene in a boot like sitting on a
table yeah I just I couldn't believe my
eyes like a little hard work they could
have figured it out it seemed like they
really just like put a bandaid on it and
he's like people were getting up said
they censored a lot of like words or
curse words and it took away from the
show but it was like it was a weird
choice of show to begin with because if
you have to censor it because it's like
inappropriate well then the host show is
were technically inappropriate yeah you
know yeah what words didn't they put him
I guess dildo and then curse words
okay dildo I kind of understand that but
I missed but it's like the whole show is
has that sort of undertones yeah like
it's like what I don't know it was
really like really bad and honestly
Roger like he needed an understudy
because his voice sucked anyway and that
kid like Jordan Fischer who guys the
Disney Channel star like like what it
was so weird like they didn't explain
anything he was like had a video
recorder the whole time it's like okay
you see a filmmaker I don't know I don't
know it's like you really had to have
been a rent expert to enjoy right if
you're watching subjects yeah it doesn't
matter I understand Oh someone was there
there were a bunch of toasters who were
there and they were putting a picture of
videos in the group of like things
what's happening now it all looked
really just very sad it was really
depressed this it was like I have to go
on the show tomorrow and like take a
take a dump on Renton like I just hate
when I can't say anything nice about
something so I want to take some nice
thing please um Vanessa Hudgens was
incredible a struggle and I think that
she definitely is underrated I think
that um miss darbus would have been so
proud of her and I think that Sharpay
honestly like would have finally
understood why I was so important for
Gabrielle to be in the musical okay and
that it wasn't just a side project like
she's passionate about theater and like
even when Vanessa Hudgens is in like the
the ensemble routines it's like she is
such a theater nerd she's a spirit
having the time of her life and and that
was fun to watch um I thought Tinashe
did a great job
okay um I thought this set was nice I
said that I thought you know it looked
like the musicians were having fun
everyone was like they were having fun
that's what you wanted and then they
brought out the original cast which was
a nice touch okay I think that's enough
nice things to say I think so too and
they did something very Intune which was
they changed the hashtag for rent live
to just rent ah oh my god that's [__]
terrible cuz it was not live right right
right
I thought I was like that part didn't
even bother me it was like even if it
had been live actually I'd love live
because you never know what's gonna
happen there's always that excitement
equate they have just like delayed it
like a week figure out like advertisers
yeah sure Sox has something scheduled
for next week right I'm just saying like
it seems like there we could've done
better but whatever we could have done
better I wouldn't have minded Roger in a
wheelchair it would have added some
Flair okay is all as I'm saying
there's an final story a little like a
business that really affects everyone on
the daily like basis on a personal level
and I just want to make sure you all
know what's going on is that the cost of
stamps is jumping up to 55 stents the
biggest increase in USPS history what is
it now 50 cents the price of forever
stamps is increasing by 10% and we'll go
from 50 cents to 55 cents according to
USPS press release while they have a PR
person for the mail but so what if I
have a stamp now and I want to use it in
a month
I think you're okay I think you're okay
but now it's just going forward
stamps are costing Beau and honestly I
just had to buy like 300 stamps for my
imitation it's so expensive and I'm just
so glad that this happened before before
but like when we were in camp and we
just have to send letters it was like 37
cents in this inflation it's crazy like
when I was a kid you could send a letter
for 30 cents you could sneak it into the
postman messenger bag that is so crazy
actually no if you just leave make the
return address the address where you're
actually trying to send it it's it's as
our campers call it free mail yeah it's
also a mail fraud but whatever oh is it
the mail is like serious like you get
arrested for mail [__] I know yesterday
Zach was opening my packages I was like
I'm gonna let you finish and then I'm
calling the cops good please just get
rid of the boxes yeah don't open
whatever you want the first-class mail
forever stamp price will take effect
January 27th Wow
yesterday and Dena's birthday I blame
her the federal agency said NBC Bay Area
reports that the change is the biggest
jump in the history of USPS
although the price is increasing old
forever stance will remain valid for a
mailing letter regardless how much the
price changes think the price change
will offset a four billion dollar loss
the federal agency experienced in 2018 I
was like are we have to cover the cost
because some [__] can't budget per
usual according to NBC Bay Area USPS
said sales from shipping and packages
soared 10 percent last year but there
was an overall decline in revenue duty
due to rising pay and higher
transportation costs and also because
like UPS is doing it better than you
yeah so is FedEx the first forever stamp
was issued in to set 2007 for 41 cents
oh so it was never but it's like how did
they what were stamps before forever
Sam's
right they were just like stamps in
November what's the difference not not
sure
in November USPS announced that dancer
gregory hines singer mark marvin gaye
and a hearts blossom stamp would be
added to the forever collection for 2019
that's when you've made it when you're
on a stamp that's the shoe be our goal
it's the stamp of approval truly that
should be our 11:11 goal oh I mean you
can also make custom stamps and just put
your face on it that's what I did for my
wife not just like so you know you make
your own you make your own goals
ya come true your dreams hmm man that
those five really took it out of me they
were I told you they were gonna be a
heavy five so what's on tonight we got
banner from pearls in The Bachelor which
will we will be recapping tomorrow
yes um yeah okay just you know the usual
business about what this was a show
really dedicated to the past five and it
was like truly one hour
ladies and gentlemen it has been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
I'm gonna go throw up bye
you